en deux mots son mandat était de
réfléchir à comment québec peut faire
des économies des économies
structurelles
année après année qui reviendrait donc
bref amoindrir les coûts de l'état
québécois
parmi la foule de propositions et à la
deux qui ont retenu l'attention de
redonner à ottawa la perception des
impôts on n'en parlera pas tout à
l'heure on ne parlait tout à l'heure à
l'émission mon vent reparler c'est
certain mais l'on s'intéresse à cette
recommandation de briser le monopole de
la saq
depuis longtemps les avaient identifié
pour faire un débat sur ce sujet là ça
tombe bien je voulais présenter orishas
un économiste directeur de la recherche
à l'esprit quand le mec de montréal
monsieur chasse un bon soir à vous
bonsoir
et vous êtes vous pour la fin du
monopole dont vous applaudissez n'est ce
pas davantage de concurrence très bien
et contre la fin de ce monopole
simon tremblay pépin de chercheurs issus
de recherche et d'informations
socio-économiques vous êtes faut garder
ça totalement public
tout à fait bonsoir voila alors on va
écouter si vous le voulez bien
un petit extrait de l'entrevue que
lucienne robillard m'a donné sur ce
sujet là pour vient pour débattre tout
fait après commencions par la saq malin
brebières expliquez-nous votre logique
que vous dites la saq a pris de
l'embonpoint ça coûte trop cher trop de
frais d'administration par rapport aux
autres sociétés comparables au canada
donc vous voulez mettre une concurrence
directe
oui une concurrence directe en
libéralisant le marché ce qui
permettrait à des entreprises privées de
vendre aussi des vins et des spiritueux
alors ça va obliger la saq a regardé de
très près ces frais d'administration et
de rentrer en concurrence avec d'autres
vous savez monsieur roy que c'est très
rare que quand nous avons un monopole
qu'ils soient publics ou privés que ça
serve bien consommateurs mais c'est une
machine à imprimer de l'argent est la
saq pour le gouvernement 1,6 milliard
cette année
est ce que selon votre formule lady
vidal ne baisseraient pas
automatiquement n'ont absolument pas le
gouvernement peut garder exactement les
mêmes revenus au niveau de la taxe vous
le savez très bien le gouvernement tout
les habilités pour statuer sur le niveau
des taxes et donc il pourrait conserver
le même revenu mais en même temps le
consommateur pourrait y gagner aussi
parce qu'ils auraient une concurrence
qui se ferait dans le marché alors il
est temps qu'on regarde de près ce
monopole public qui existe depuis très
longtemps au québec et je pense que la
raison d'être de la saq et pas
strictement de procurer des revenus au
gouvernement mais aussi de bien servir
les consommateurs les membres bien
d'abord il faut dire pour que les gens
comprennent vous avait exclu le scénario
le plus dramatique c'est à dire vendre
la saq au complet là oui absolument
le discours depuis quelques années était
sur la privatisation mais la
privatisation voudrait dire qu'on va
transférer le monopole public un
monopole privé le consommateur va pas
une gagnée pour autant
alors ce qu'on veut c'est de la
concurrence dans le marché qui est qu
elle qu elle s appuie donc soit plus
performante dans ce qu'elle fait pour
être capable donc d'être compétitive et
que le consommateur y gagne
mais pour le consommateur expliquez moi
comment on pourrait retrouver nos
bouteilles de vin ou les spiritueux
moins cher puisque pour compenser la
baisse des dividendes augmentent auriez
la proportion de taxes la met au même
niveau donc ça change absolument rien
pour le consommateur
sauf que six à mieux pour nous là non
pas que le consommateur excusez moi je
me suis trompé pour le gouvernement
ça changera absolument rien dividendes
et taxe qui serait donc transféré en
taxes c'est le même montant que le
gouvernement pourrait recevoir et il y
aura différentes formes que le
gouvernement pour étudier pour le
consommateur par ailleurs étant donné
que la société serait en concurrence
avec un marché privé on pourrait
s'attendre à ce que les frais
d'administration diminue
et donc le consommateur pourrait y
gagner à l'heure actuelle le modèle est
en train de s'effriter graduellement
d'avoir par la main par la vente en
ligne par les consommateurs qui vont
dans d'autres provinces canadiennes
acheter leurs vins et spiritueux par les
gros magasin entrepôt qui ont commencé à
vendre du main alors je pense qu'il faut
à être à l'avant-garde puis regarder ce
qu'on dit au gouvernement
voulez-vous réévaluer le modèle
d'affaires des salles plus est pour vous
le diagnostic
madame robillard et ynet même si la saq
on envoyait un communiqué ce matin en
disant que vous aviez pas eu accès à
tous les livres entre j'ai pris les
documents publics
mais pour vous c'est clair que ça coûte
plus cher ici qu'ailleurs administrer la
saq
c'est très clair et les chiffres le
démontrent dans notre rapport est ce qui
va être important pour nous c'est de
savoir ce que le gouvernement entend
faire pour rendre le sens qu plus
performants d'abord et avant tout et
ensuite d'essayer de regarder et de voir
si la libéralisation du marché serait
pas une avenue possible le fait que les
charges administratives de la saq soit à
un niveau plus élevé que celle d'un
monopole comparables ça ça nous alerte
sur le fait qu'il ya des gains
d'efficience aller chercher et mon
collègue le ministre des finances va
déjà tout de suite demandé ça la saq ça
fait partie de notre plan d'ajustement
des quoi très concrètement de diminuer
la charge les charges administratives
par rapport aux ventes de telle sorte
que on pourra avoir un dividende accru
lié à une plus grande efficience de la
saq polje a le plus grand un prix plus
élevé pour les bouteilles plastiques
pour cela vous êtes convaincus que le
diagnostic est bon ça coûte plus cher
vente du vin ainsi que ce que les autres
rien font ce que dans d'autres provinces
ont fait on est convaincu que la saq
peut faire mieux en la matière alors
voilà débat maintenant youri chassin
vous êtes pour une forme de
privatisation mais vous arrêter pour
vous de privatisation complète peut-être
la saq lot d'entrée de faire entrer de
la concurrence vous ça vous sourit
absolument donc c'est évidemment bon en
tant qu'économiste j'ai ce biais
et s'il ya bien une leçon qu'on peut
retenir de l'économie c'est qu'un
monopole qu'ils soient privés ou qu'ils
soient publics un monopole c'est
toujours une structure de marché qui
difficile pour le consommateur est
essentiellement la saq c'est un monopole
qui a été historique il ya très
longtemps il faut le rappeler en 1922
dans temps de la prohibition et à
l'époque on était peut-être un peu à
l'avant garde on était moins puritains
que ceux qui demandaient d'enfants une
production complète mais aujourd'hui
c'est un modèle qui est complètement
dépassé qu'à près de 100 ans et qu'il
faut remettre en question parce que y'en
à la concurrence mais elle est très
limité c'est plein d'irritants les
épiceries par exemple ne peuvent pas
indiqué le cépage sur le vin il y a
vraiment un marché difficile pour la
concurrence et qui plus est je pense que
c'est ça le fond de la question pour la
commission robillard c est ce qu il
s'agit là d'une mission de l'état
quand on pense à halle et on s'est dit
bon l'éducation la santé cds domaine
clair mais est ce que la vente de pinot
noir ou de bordeaux ça doit vraiment
faire partie mais l'expression la
commission propose poursuivre la vente
d'alcool une saq mais y aurait de la
concurrence à côté simon tremblay popeye
pourquoi pas de la concurrence d'un ça
qu il faut voir si ça marche ailleurs
étonnamment la commission ne s'est pas
penché sur cette question on a très peu
de comparaisons en fait les seuls
chiffres que dans ce rapport madame
aubière vous les audi cette comparaison
des coûts administratifs sur les ventes
on ne veut même pas plus loin pourrait
poser la question mais combien coûte un
employé à la saq par rapport à la haye
si bio en ontario on verrait que les
coûts sont un pis aller voir les frais
d'administration
oui parce que c'est le fondement de tout
l'argumentaire de ce rapport là non
c'est pas de fondement c'est ce sont les
seuls chiffres disponibles dans le
rapport et ses amis qui sont alors la
saq 21% ontario 16% colombie-britannique
10 pour ça mais ça vous dit c'est un
choix de société vous que de mieux payés
par exemple les employés de la saq que
ben écoute et où on peut effectivement
bien payer les employés de la saq et ça
peut être un choix de société
ce que saab la saq dans son communiqué
aujourd'hui disait grâce à nos dépenses
en termes d'administration on parvient à
voir des croissances de vente plus
rapide que les autres commission des
liqueurs et cetera ailleurs ou ailleurs
au canada
eh bien il me semble que là un argument
intéressant est ce que la commission
revient à étudier pas du tout alors on
se retrouve devant un très très minces
document on fait même pas le débat des
bottes dans lequel monsieur chassaing et
moi avons développé une certains experts
r spec expertise après le temps on fait
même pas le débat sur les prix à savoir
est-ce que c'est moins cher en alberta
est ce que c'est moins cher en colombie
britannique où il ya des éléments gouin
et les réalisations
même ça ça n'existe pas moi je suis tout
à fait prêt à faire le débat sur la saq
mais me semble qu'on est là quelque
chose de très minces monsieur quoi tu le
reconnaît d'ailleurs il dit on va faire
davantage d'études et on va aller un peu
plus loin aller chercher des études
sérieuses
si vous cherchez des études sérieuses et
qui n'ont pas un entraînement monsieur
chat c'est vous c'est comme vous l'avez
dit vous poser la question pourquoi
l'état détiendrait le monopole de la
vente d'alcools et de spiritueux dans
une société
al'inverse posons nous la question à
linverse regardons la bière en ontario
il ya des bears troy dans des magasins
ou en vin la bière en exclusivité ça
n'existait pas au québec et d'ailleurs
qu'elle réussit c'est une industrie où
il ya énormément d'innovation où il ya
des microbrasseries qui se sont taillé
une place enviable et je pense qu'on
serait vraiment à mal de trouver des
arguments en faveur d'un monopole sur la
bière ce serait insensé
dans la même optique je pense que oui il
n'y a peut-être comme monsieur tremblay
taper le souligner il y as peut-être des
endroits où il ya des gens qui vont se
dire ben écoutez il faut faire attention
à tes l'aspect ou à tel aspect mais les
arguments contre davantage de
concurrence contre d'autres modèles ça
il y en a très peu et en fait
contrairement à ce que ce monde il ya
vraiment plusieurs études parce que ça
fait longtemps qu'on en débatte cette
question là il ya plusieurs études qui
ont été mis de l'avant depuis en fait
non seulement aider
et même davantage donc on a vraiment une
perspective on change pas le mot d'amour
c'est un québécois pour le consommateur
monsieur tremblay un peu ps que c'est
pas tremblé peu parce que c'est pas une
des lois qu'on apprend en première année
d'économie s'écria de la concurrence les
prix ont tendance à chuter et que donc
ça va être profitable pour les
consommateurs mais remarquez que le
gouvernement va taxer davantage de toute
façon gouvernement nous annonce qu'il va
taxer davantage comme ça s'est passé en
alberta ou que le gouvernement augmenter
de façon très importante ces taxes qui
lorsqu'il a privatisé regarder une
enquête que fait la commission
l'association des des régies des alcools
à travers le canada
elle essayait de voir qu'elle était dans
quelle province ont payé le 20 le moins
cher les trois premières c'est le
nunavut
l'ontario et la saskatchewan trois
systèmes publics
le québec se classe en 5e avant
l'albertain donc si on veut parler de
prix il ne faut pas seulement se référer
à des principes abstraits fallait
regarder qu'est ce qui se passe
effectivement sur le terrain et dans le
code de l'alcool
au canada ce sont les monopoles publics
qui font mieux que la saq là dessus je
vais rejoindre monsieur coiteux si on
veut s'inspirer de la n6 bio si on
trouve quelque chose d'intéressant qui
se font en ontario mais très bien voyons
qu'est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant
étudiants ce n'est pas de la commission
revient qui nous offre sa aujourd'hui
comme elle n'aborde pas ces questions
mais je tremblais peu peur vous regarder
des chiffres si ce que ça rapporte je le
dirai plus demain entrevue avec madame
robillard il ya une seconde c'est une
une planche à imprimer de l'argent pour
les gouvernements du québec c'est une
évidence
1 milliards en dividendes 600 millions
en taxes donc c'est 1 milliard 600
millions qu'on a envoyés dans les
coffres du mystère des finances hélas y
ait de la concurrence les dividendes
baissent rêve ce qu'elle est ça qu en
vendrait moins mais les taxes
augmenterait quoi ce serait pour le
gouvernement et chasser ce serait
l'équivalent exactement donc la
commission robillard a calculé que c'est
l'équivalent de 5 $ 30 par litre que le
consommateur paye dans ce qui devient un
dividende pour le gouvernement donc le
milliard et c'est possible de le
remplacer par exemple par une taxe donc
pour le gouvernement ça ne change rien
évidemment la concurrence la difficulté
c'est que c'est un phénomène dynamique 1
des nouveaux modèles qui émergent il y a
dans le fond des consommateurs qui
recherchent un service particulièrement
d'autres recherche de meilleurs prix
donc contrairement un sinon je pense
qu'il faut pas seulement regarder une
seule une seule un seul critère est par
ailleurs on regarde il faut bien le
regarder mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on
s'entendra pas ni lui ni moi ce soir
par contre il pourra toujours magasiner
à la saq d'entre eux la concurrence et
moi j'irai ailleurs exactement le modèle
proposerait deux systèmes unix
finalement pour fouetter c'est
l'intention du gouvernement aux le sang
fouetter la saq pour que ça coûte moins
cher les l'innovation où ça le croit et
on y est il loin il y est loin d'être
sûr que ça fonctionnera parce que si on
dit aux grossistes en épicerie
occupez-vous de vendre du vin on peut
être sûr que c'est pas là qu'on aura des
bons conseils ou toutes ces choses que
mon collègue recherche
ben voilà mais on verra tout ça merci
beaucoup travaillé peuple et monsieur
chat c'est pour être venu nous voir
discuter de cette question
on va reparler mais ressaisir